hello i'm the british journalist and
broadcaster emma barnett and i'm here to
tell you about my new show on bloomberg
quick take called emma barnett meets
i meet opinion formers international
leaders cultural icons and those at the
forefront of our world
and have a proper conversation in a
large blue room on two company chairs is
facebook a platform or a publisher it's
a platform in my view because it sounds
terribly like a publisher i think the
election
of joe biden and the four years of
donald trump has divided the united
states more than i've seen it in my
lifetime the facts are the facts right
no i don't think it does a fact using a
fact which is not working it's to figure
out
it's very good
[Music]
if possible if you understand let me
finish understanding you stop
personalizing this you have no idea what
i think and you're not relevant
i'm quoting you're making a big mistake
from putin's point of view exactly i
mean look the united states looks like
it was finished vladimir putin would
have probably just you know driven right
into ukraine himself is there a a phrase
or a word that you think is far better
in sign
[Music]
when it's spilled over gone that's a fun
moment the famous one was derek gizora
and dillian white where he picked up the
table some great photos of that what
gets you out of bed in the morning what
motivates you you could have been having
i think i have one of the most
interesting jobs in the world that's why
i applied for it and is it right
weinstein asked for more hair
in one of your drawings oh yeah he did
he was walking out with his lawyers and
he looked over at my sketch and he said
can't you give me more hair
the best dressed man i think i've had in
the studio thank you i'm gonna take that
i love heavy metal i always love of
course you do that's exactly what i
thought when you walked in today as soon
as i got covered just like this every
nerve ending in my body just started to
kind of tingle or buzz and it has just
been sort of constant now for two years
how happy are you with the digital world
it is a right but it's not something you
can take for granted you have to fight
for officials from china ever since have
done as much as they can to have as much
control at the who i can tell you that
there's no truth behind those
allegations in many ways it's the
survival
of the fittest if you don't stop putting
we will have a nuclear war thank you so
much for being with us until we meet
again take care and goodbye
you